はじめんのーーーーーーーーーーー
バスケットボール講座ーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーー！！
うわあっ！
こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです
最近、バスケットボールにはまっていて
この前もバスケットボールをするためだけに東京に行ってきました
多分この動画を見てる人では
バスケットボールを上手くなりたいと思ってる人もいると思う
で、バスケットボールを上手くなるために
まず試合で必要になるのは
皆、速いパス来たら怖いよね
僕も最初は怖かったさ
先輩から流れるキラーボール
何人の人が突き指したか
病院送りになった人もいたよ
そう、バスケットの試合において最も...あ、最もでもねぇわ
シュートが一番大事だ
バスケットに求められるのはシュートなんだが
シュートまで行くためにはやっぱパスをもらう必要があるんだ
こういう感じにね
で、多分バスケット初めてやる人はパスをもらうのが難しいし
速いパスがくると怖いので
今回、僕は研究を重ねて
誰でも確実に
どんなパスでも受け取ることができるようになる
トレーニング方法を見つけました
これを実践すれば
この動画を見ている君
君もどんなパスでも受け取ることが出来る最強のバスケプレイヤーになれる。
今日は早速それを実践していこうと思うよ
ではいこう
バスケットボールっていうのは何が怖いかって言うと
たまにものすごい場所にパスしてくる人もいるよね
でも試合中はそんなこと言ってはいられない
どんな場所にパスが来ても
受け取るような練習をしてればいいと思ったので
僕は今回こちら
階段にぶつかることによってあらゆるランダム性が起きてしまう
16段の階段があるので
この16段の階段を降りる中
バスケットボールは何を思うかというと
いろんなカクカクがあるから、すごいこうなんか
一番下に僕がいるんですけど
到着するまでにどんな動きになってるかは
読めない⭐︎
読めない！
が、それをキャッチしなければいけない
これを繰り返すことによって
どんなパスにも対応できる
最強の...あの...
じゃあまず
俺練習したら　まじ9000発ぐらいまで
いけると思うんだけど
よし、行きます！
(ボールがバウンドする音)
うんうん...
待って、なんか違う
これを繰り返すだけです　本当に
(ボールがバウンドする音)
オォォシィ
アァァァァァ
(ボールがバウンドする音)
よし
オォシィ
アァァァァァ
アァァァッ
ウワァァァッ
抹茶ぁぁぁぁ
オォォォアァァァ
へい
(ボールがバウンドする音)
(骨が折れる効果音)
アァァァァァ
ハァ、ハァ...
うぅ
だぁぁぁぁ
投げてもらう人の速度を上げてもらうと
より、アグレッシブな
パスが受け取れるようになります
あぁ
(ボールがバウンドする音)
あーーー！
あーーー！まってまって！完全に玉入った完全に玉入った！
まあここまでは問題なくこれた
さらなるパスをキャッチしたいみんなへ
最終ステップとしてボールを二つ転がしてもらうのもある
これは二つのボールを一気に取らなきゃいけないからディフェンスの練習にもなります
広い視野を持つことによってさらにオフェンスディフェンスの幅が広がる
そういう練習法になってます！
かつボールのキャッチ力も付く！やってみましょう！
(2つのボールがバウンドする音)
(リプレイでご覧いただきましょう)
(笑い声)
(2つのボールがバウンドする音)
う、うわーーーーーーー！いて！